hello this is minus i'm gonna try
uh a test which is supposed to be pretty
hard okay this is already too hard for
me
oh no
actually actually not yet
how about this one rook d6 g4
okay this is
something
probably very well known
so i think check first check first
and mate
okay
so far so good is this some sort of
i think this is some sort of
variation of the legals mate
all right
what is this
what in the world is this
probably takes on h6
hmm
now let's take that bone checks
checks
this is already too hard
okay maybe checks maybe this one
this one
[Music]
okay
this one i can't see at first glance
rook h6 there's queen
c5
oh that actually still works yeah
queen c5 king h1 queen c1 they were
still made by bishop b6
oh this one is nice i mean i'm i'm
actually sure i've seen the game
kasparov smearing i'm pretty sure that
was king's indian actually yeah i was
against india
ah what's going on
okay this is the back rank this is
something i got
so there is mating one so we should
be sure to make
to deliberate with checks
too hard for me already
and i needed another test
i actually need another test
probably queen d5 is smart but i can get
free
i don't know queen queen what whatever
okay queen b1
we need to and queen okay this is just
matching three
so
it helps that um
how's this one there queen death
no not queen d3
queen b1
oh this one is nice yeah
okay queen a2
probably takes check
okay this is very cheap
these are these are not easy i would say
this one is pretty easy though because
you don't have
oh
oh my god
i thought it was going to go to king g8
and then there would be knight e6 in
rook g7 yeah that was knight g6 of
course and then and then uh
and then rook 8 okay
okay next one
this seems also rather simple
okay checks
okay this is made right knight
take on h3
and
take everything
okay let's go to the next one
what's going on okay this is d2 pawn for
sure
that's something that
feels incredibly good to know okay i can
make it play queen c5 king
e4 bishop f5 and this is
whoa hang on this is a mate
is this mate
next way to okay now i see
to win oh
it's actually
it's actually amazing too
wow
this is a mate you could play this
madison okay
actually i played against matthias
bennick in 2003
uh in
in black open
and i lost
so what's this
bishop g7 it takes 28
protects
not so clutterful
though
i'm just taking f7 and play queen f7
maybe there is just no need for any
brilliancy
okay pretty much rook and then says bro
and i say the queen i think rook was
also correct uh this is going
a bit shaky
i gotta just take on e7 and then queen
of seven
i don't wanna i don't wanna mate i just
wanna win the game
yeah i just wanna win the game
okay this is simple
that's okay though
oh this one is easy standard mate fish
basics
or exhaust this
rookie 4 in e5 likely
nice no not over yet yeah okay
where's the mates
here's the mate opening up for the
bishop and queen of fort